Southwest Airlines faces a new federal
investigation this morning after the
company's second midair scare in about
two weeks a window cracked during a
flight from Chicago to Newark yesterday
photos from inside the plane show the
large jagged split that's terrifying
Southwest says the plane never lost
cabin pressure and diverted safely to
Cleveland just over two weeks ago an
engine explosion caused a window to
break mid-flight a woman died after she
was partially sucked out of the aircraft
Kris Van Cleave is at Phoenix Sky Harbor
International Airport Chris good morning
good morning now this cracked window
comes as Southwest is facing increased
scrutiny and a drop in bookings because
of that deadly accident a couple of
weeks ago one that was certainly on the
minds of the 81 passengers on board this
flight we heard a loud let you like a
loud boom I just said to my friend I was
sitting next to me that that's not
normal I'm not sure what that was
passengers on Southwest flight 9 57 were
33,000 feet in the air when a window
suddenly cracked it was a little
frightening I fly all the time for work
this is the most disturbing flight I've
ever had
kara O'Grady was sitting just a few feet
away it went all around the outside and
but it just sounded like a really loud
pop like you know someone's throwing a
rock at you no but I looked over I went
oh gosh you know and jumped out of the
seat as soon as possible
the windows on a 737 have three
components a pressure seal and two
acrylic window panes if the outer pane
fails that second one is designed to
maintain cabin pressure as it did on
flight 9 57 even the loss of a piece of
one of them should not necessarily take
the entire window out former NTSB
chairman Mark Rosen Kerr says the flight
crew was right to make a quick landing
even though the plane never lost cabin
pressure the 737 is the workhorse of the
commercial aviation world these are very
reliable very safe aircraft this is an
anomaly the reality is you can continue
to fly an airplane for decades as long
as it's maintained to the manufacturers
standards
it's the latest mid-air incident aboard
a 737
two weeks ago Southwest flight 1380 had
to make an emergency landing when an
engine blew sending shrapnel through a
window and killing a passenger the plane
is 20 years old but Southwest says the
window is newer than that and was last
inspected in April the airline tells CBS
this morning in a statement the aircraft
has been taken out of service for
maintenance review and that safety is a
safety of our customers and employees is
our number one focus each and every day
passengers are praising the flight crew
for their professionalism during the
incident biana Wow yet again within just
a matter of weeks an anomaly or not that
is still a frightening yes can you
imagine being sitting next to that
window after what happened with the last
no I can't Chris our thanks to you